Speaking of like giving like five stars and one stars and stuff like that.
Have we ever talked about what, like the reviewing mentality is here in Japan?
Just everything.
I noticed that right away when I moved here. Yeah.
How like nothing on Amazon is above.
Yeah. It's not just not on Amazon.
Like everything on like Google or Google maps. Yeah. Stuffing.
If like hardly anything is above four stars. It's like,
mostly is then it's only like two reviews. Right. And also like.
Uh, so they do use Google reviews, uh, mainly for like restaurants and stuff,
but there's also a thing called Tagalog that they like a lot of people think
that food critics use and it should be.
Like the Yelp of Japan. Basically. It's.
Insane because it's like,
these people review these food restaurants and like three stars for a restaurant
is considered good. Yeah. That's like, it's done it. It's, it's impressive.
Because I remember when I first moved to Japan and whenever you'd look up
restaurants and Google, you see like three, 3.5 stars,
maybe the occasional four and in England or in America,
when I see a three-star restaurant, I'm like, yo,
something's gone wrong for that. I'm just like,
[inaudible] man. Like, I don't know. I don't understand.
I don't understand what that is.
Like do the Japanese think that the stars on Google reviews like Michelin stars,
like, cause I mean, I understand it because they actually,
I respect that they have a mentality where they literally actually used every
star in the review system. Cause it's like the mal review. Right?
Where anything below, like, I I'm pretty sure like mallow 70. Yeah.
I'm pretty sure like Maldon,
mal users don't realize that fi like under five stars actually exist. Um,
because it's either like seven, if it's good. Um, six is really bad.
Six is really bad. Like five is the most awful animators.
Every restaurant I, the way I am.
I imagine it is like, what would I tell the owner?
If he was right in front of me now? Like,
would I genuinely sit there and be like, this is a three-star experience.
You know what I mean? Like how are you going to.
Do that to the poor guys? Should I run a business? Right? Yeah. It's just to me,
you know, if I go somewhere, I really like the food.
I have nothing bad about it. How in good faith. Can I be like, yeah,
you don't deserve five stalls. Yeah.
Because there was nothing wrong with it. Like this.
Was exactly what I wanted. I got what I needed. Yeah. It wasn't fine dining.
It wasn't crazy. Yeah.
Like there was nothing. Oh, sorry. I was going to say it like,
that's the thing I want to ask about these like super harsh Japanese reviews,
right? It's like, what is a five-star? Yeah. It's like,
do you want a blow job from the chefs? Like also another thing where like you,
how can you judge.
Really a restaurant the same way? McDonald's.
Yeah, because like, Hey,
because what I was going to say is even like the fine dining restaurants are the
same because they expect a fine dining experience.
So if they get the fine dining experience,
that's the standard that you've done the job.
And so that makes me wonder what the would a fine dining restaurant have to do
to get a four or five star? Man.
It blows my mind because like, like I said,
like comparing McDonald's to like a fine dining experience because they really
shouldn't be on the same. Right. Cause that totally different things. Yeah.
So when you go to McDonald's, what are you judging about?
McDonald's are you judging the place, the food? What are you judging?
Because the food isn't going to change really?
It's probably not going to be any different.
The only thing that determines a good McDonald's experience or a bad one,
it's like how fast?
Yeah. This is what I see on Google reviews.
I'll see a two-star McDonald's and I'll see a four-star and I'm like,
what is the difference? Not like, ultimately I cannot tell the difference. Yes.
It might be dirty or whatever.
Less fries than I ordered last time. That's what confuses me.
Because then I'm then I'm also like, okay,
so if I rate this McDonald's a five star, uh,
what am I reading at a five-star off? Am I rating it on a five-star because.
The other McDonald's compared to a bigger question is who the is raiding
McDonald's and pupil.
Okay. Ducks would be rude, but you know, people who are like, yeah,
see it's my only fine dining experience. I will review every McDonald's right.
People would call McDonald's a restaurant. The same people will call motels,
hotels, you know?
No, it's the, every single, like really, really high rated place in Japan,
like four or five, four or 0.5 Ohio. Yeah.
There's normally light and disgusting. Wait time to get the food. Yeah.
Because when you get to that star in Japan,
I feel like you get like it almost like a fandom,
like a hype around a cold following. Yeah.
So then everyone starts telling everyone just like, yo, yo,
you gotta get there early. You gotta line up. And it's like, well.
Now I can't enjoy the place. I got to make it three.
Date events resume. I noticed that as well,
where there's Japan's restaurant culture.
Especially if something is like highly acclaimed,
it all spreads via word of mouth. Japanese love lining up. I don't know.
I don't get that as a British training.
I can appreciate a good Q a but there's as a British person,
I can appreciate a good queue as well, but not to a restaurant.
You know what I mean? I can't stand cues, dude. Yeah. If I want to,
if I want to go to a good restaurant, that's exclusive, please. Let me book it,
please. Please. Don't I don't want another gutter system.
I don't want to line up.
I want just to have a booking and a specific time I turn up,
um, or you could be like us and try to book a table at Denny's
and completely fail. Cause we,
cause we always eat Denny's before we record a podcast and we had like, Oh,
one of the guests over and we're like, Oh.
That's a lot of people we might have to book a table at Denny's.
So we were like, which to, to give context,
it's like trying to book a table at McDonald's.
So Marlene called up Denny's and was like, ah, can we book a table for six?
And the guy came back and was like, this is a Denny's.
Why are you trying to book a table? Just come to the restaurant.
This is Denny's. Who was it? It wasn't like,
like he caught it. He caught like the manager or something. It was like, wait.
Yeah,
we went to, they do reservations. Yeah. Danny Danny's so exclusive.
You have to turn up on the day.
It's it's it's the most polite way you can just say it's a Denny's.
Why are you calling what the wrong with.
Going back to like normal reviews of products? Like all the products.
I like that as well. And like,
if you see something with fully five stars on Amazon with over like 20 reviews,
you're like, this must be like the. Yeah.
Because they're paying for those reviews. Cause I remember when I was buying,
like going back last week, buying a bed,
I could not find a bed over like three stars on Amazon.
I remember that like there was no bed that was about three stars. And I'm like,
who, how many problems we will have them with beds. And I would go to the, uh,
the reviews to read what they were saying.
And they were all saying that the build was too long. And that was the problem.
I've had. I've had some of the most pedantic reviews of Japanese hammers.
I've I've had like, someone wants our product because the packaging was bad.
It's completely fine. The packaging was a bit off. So they were like,
once that's what drives me.
Insane is that they,
they almost always review this around what you're actually reviewing. Yeah.
All the delivery man had a bad attitude.
It's. Like I, if the package is a little beat up, but the thing's totally fine.
Yeah.
Fantastic. Are going to throw out the packaging anyway.
Like as long as I can use the thing I need. So what, like, I,
this shouldn't be a blight on the company that sent me it. Like, this is absurd.